today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza
sometimes you don't know what you want
to do and you're just standing around
somewhere well you can change all that
go to grey block pizza and fill your
holes
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach in Los Angeles gray block pizza
get that hitter today's episode is
brought to you by minimal case it's the
world's thinnest phone case everything's
on a diet these days and phone cases are
no different I saw a phone case the
other day vomiting in the bathroom the
minimal case is the world's thinnest
case just point zero one inches thick
that's barely thick at all currently
minimal is having cases for the new
iPhone excesses xrs and pixel threes
those are in stock the minimal case
showcases the beauty of your phone I'm
talking thin this isn't the type of case
you can throw your phone or you're gonna
drop it down the stairs or you're gonna
you know clumsily let it fly off your
lap and you're getting out of the car
that's not this this is that sleek outer
piece this is that sealskin this is
something special something thin for
your case and it comes with a hundred
percent money-back guarantee if you are
unhappy for whatever reason whatever
reason even if someone in your family is
just making you mad and you want a
refund for your phone case they'll do it
no need to even send the case back get
20% off by visiting em in ml case CAS
e.com and use promo code Theo
that's promo code th EO for 20% off at
MN ml CA se minimal case dot-com today's
episode is uh we're featuring today one
of the last white Heroes I would say you
know this man he's got his own sick ELA
he's been drinking so long and
entertaining so long that he he didn't
develop alcoholism but he definitely had
just developed his own alcohol and it's
called number one and he is he is a he
is
nothing short of a trailblazer this man
has been performing for a long time out
of Texas it's my mother's favorite
comedian and one of mine as well I'm
honored to be actually going this will
be in his home today where we are it is
mr. ron wyden did you ever meet this is
probably before your time to giver me
jerry Clower yeah yeah still doing gigs
I'd see him he'd come to like play high
school auditoriums and stuff yeah but
but I did enjoy the work yeah yeah his
albums I loveless I still listen to his
albums oh yeah yeah one of them's like
one of the all-time highest selling
comedy albums ever I got I think it's
like Greatest Hits or something but yeah
man thanks for letting us be in here
today
sure welcome to tater lands yeah I know
huh the house that comedy built her one
of right and you got this dog here named
mustard yeah mustard won't leave us
alone by the way okay he'll never chill
he'll uh he want you to throw that paw
somewhere I think we're probably gonna
have to lock him up what do you think
mustard he's handsome huh yeah why don't
you go ahead and take him downstairs
where's he from what country or city is
he from he's from he was born somewhere
in Kentucky and I bought him when I was
living in Atlanta right before him of
Deadwood laughs I bought him for me and
I bought this Australian Shepherd for my
mother oh nice he likes animals yeah
mother mother does and what she likes
dogs yeah I think they have a cat or
with her too but would your mom do
whenever you were growing up did what
did your mom work or just your dad
worked
now another work she had a
the earliest one of the earliest
memories I have is she was a cashier in
this little grocery store and this
little tiny dirt town in Texas and and
my mother beautiful beautiful land so
she was man I guess she'd have been
twenty five or six in this little bitty
dusty town they you know she was
probably the only true you know hot babe
in the whole city they wanted her to
stay I bet ya they did they took a hit
yeah people don't realize yeah like you
get kind of used to in some of these
bigger cities like seeing a lot of
beautiful ladies but in smaller towns it
was like that one girl you know right
you imagine the town Christie Brinkley
grew up in Oklahoma they were like uh
you're going where I'm going to okay
follow Christie you know I remember they
had this girl in our town this girl
named Chrissy hunt and she wasn't even
she was just on our street but she had
like a chipped tooth but she was like
the first girl that like showed me any
attention and I just remember thinking
that took her to like another level you
know that can happen the to throw
there's the fact that she cared I think
I don't know which one probably a little
bit of both combination plate yeah that
chip in the tooth let me know that you
know she you know if we got in a
relationship she'd be able to go through
some things you know I think all right
there was some value in that so but and
you're married now no you're not married
now I don't know man I don't know what
it is no I'm not married I'm going
through a thing with somebody that's
claiming we were married but we weren't
yeah so and it's gonna be a big you know
it's a big uncomfortable things is that
up is that is like is that upsetting or
is it like kind of scary or is it just
well you know it I was just hoping we
could all be fair you know yeah and the
fact that we can't be you know we that
you know it's
it was also you know of a family ties
also and her brother and I are partners
and the tequila company and oh yeah
number one right good for his mother
mother and I've known him all for 30
years and my mother and her mother
really good friends and so you know I
hoped it wouldn't end up in in in court
but that's where it's gonna be dang you
know if somebody else trying to chip a
chip a hunk off yeah for themselves and
that's disheartening huh a little bit
especially and did you feel like cuz I
know you've been married before me nah I
met your most recent wife I just know
that you had been married before I know
that just from like the internet and
stuff but I met your most recent wife at
the Comedy Store one night this probably
maybe a year and a half ago or something
she came by would she look like I mean
this is lady was like a brunette yeah
yeah yeah yes yeah like definitely some
fire and right now she's yeah she has
she was like kind of tough yeah she was
yeah
she look like she was doing flamenco
even if she wasn't doing it you know
it's crazy crazy talented human being
yeah but we were never married so I but
I you know it's it's easier to say this
is my wife's and it is to explain it
yeah well she wouldn't sign me now so I
wouldn't sign it but you know yeah it's
just so it was kind of that's what most
people thought but was crazy talented
well the best thing I've ever heard in
my life and really a really dynamic
performer is that one of the things that
you think like attracted to you too I
remember hearing a girl sing when I was
in junior high school and it was the
first time I'd ever heard a girl sing
and play the piano and yeah I would have
married that girl right there and I
don't even know what she looked like she
could have looked she could have been a
man first time I saw her sing she was
probably right at 32 years ago and she
was like 19 years like and she's on
stage with this bad just tearing it the
[ __ ] up part I mean I've never seen
vocal performances to this day you know
likes you too classically trained opera
singer you know do play singing rock and
roll to make a living and
and uh you know right there and I was
like what what do I landed her brother
stabbed me and I kind of came out of it
really no oh that's beautiful that
sounds like a Mexican that I don't know
what that's called I feel like it's like
a New Year's Eve like I don't know I
would love to be Mexican next time I
think or Latino you know if I come back
I want my name to be one Pablo Montoya
my name is Pablo Montoya yeah it would
be great I could do that our kids or
maybe I could do Vietnamese I think that
seems exciting too you know hey yeah all
right now dude you're off you're off
you're you're young in the show now yeah
you want to be what Pablo do you think
yeah yeah I could do that I think a
Latino I would be I think I would be I
don't if I would be black yet I'll be
black like in maybe one maybe the next
time like if I did two or three
reincarnations and then I got to pick
different ones I'd be pretty cool if you
got to go through all of them you know
like all the ethnicities and all the
well you certainly have a little
different perspective you're just tired
of this white guy [ __ ] aren't you
it's red its course sometimes I feel
like it's like in America it's kind of
like it's not running its course but
it's like it's it you know thing it's
just it's getting wild out here you know
it's just very it's a lot it's even more
it's way more diverse and even when I
was young you know it's just it's
changing I guess what America has always
been like a changing place though you
know because the state of flux yeah sure
what's the town that you grew up in like
now same exactly is it yeah another
James there it was a grain elevator then
it's a grain elevator now yeah the
fridge Texas is the name of the place
and and I went back maybe 12 or 13 years
ago I was long enough ago they had
brick-and-mortar record companies that
were selling my records and so I came up
and did a show for them and Amarillo and
they gave me this big white stretch
limousine and I have a half-sister
that's in radio there and
shei and so we got in it and went back
to fridge was about sixty miles away and
I had been there since I was a kid and
we were trying to find this little house
that mother and I were talking about
today that the day before she had me she
was staying in the floors my dad my
grandpa built his house and in the next
day she came in the world yeah right
staying the whole planet yeah but it's
and I couldn't find the house and then I
went back and I remembered my mother's
house my grandmother's house is this
great big house with these little trees
but that was you know 40 something years
ago well turns out it's a little bitty
house with gigantic trees the trees got
huge and the house wasn't ever big I was
just really little right bigger than our
house if I just thought of it as the big
house with the trees so we I found it
and then I can for some reason I knew
how to get to my house from my
grandmother's house that's when we drove
straight to it and and it's just this
little bitty thing and maybe 800 square
feet little white clapboard house and
and but they were carpenters and they
built a fence and to make it fancy
they put a curved top on the fence and
that went it was low in the front and he
got a little taller and went back in the
back but they've never finished it
because my father got transferred we
moved to Houston so I wasn't still like
that seven is still I finished Wow is
exactly the same far long as it was when
my dad all right [ __ ] with building it
everybody else said a [ __ ] that's good
like that was there like sometimes if I
go do stuff that's like nostalgic like
that like it almost makes me kind of sad
you know it makes me see like the time
that I've been alive kind of do you have
any like kind of thoughts like that well
other than how totally weird it is that
anybody that plays Madison Square Garden
or Radio City Music Hall is from that
town right you know just such an obscure
place to be from
yeah I mean just you know it just the
odds are a given to one that's somebody
from that environment that was ever
gonna go through or yours you know to
find any kind of fame and fortune in
show business
yeah do you look at the town as part of
like this something that helped kind of
like do you look at it as like a you
know a place of like you know that kind
of spurned you or something do you feel
like that or you were just I was a
little kid there you know and obviously
we didn't have anything but I mean I had
a dirt yard and the same as Foxworthy
had a dirt yard we used to talk about
that yeah we would have grass or
anything some spiders and some we had
tons of horny toads I even saw a couple
of gila monsters and others I really do
lab today
yeah well the Gila monster's might be
those things live a long time I think
there's a turtle that's alive like it
said there's been a lot like 600 years
in Hawaii but it costs if you touch it
it's 5000 bucks I said it's like a fine
you get so it's got a little baby but
now I don't you know I it's a it's just
this little bitty town and it just
happens to be where I'm from and you
know I grew up in
the smellier part of Houston and in a
house that my dad built and right across
street in the high school and junior
high so you know I'm pretty you know
pretty normal I think childhood yeah did
you think like cuz I know you said that
you know like go do relay your most
recent relationship it was you know it
was what it was but I find in my life
like it's like tough I have a tough time
like you know really caring about other
people do you ever notice that kind of
stuff with you like just being as a
comedian and being like a performer and
stuff like that caring about other
people yeah I got a real level where it
feels like I I don't know I guess I
can't really explain I mean I have a
tough time like in relationships you
know so I have a tough time I think I'm
left too
because here I am yeah 61 years ago and
single yeah I guess you know I mean I
still have friends that have been
friends of mine for 50 years since I was
a kid something like those kinds of
things have always continued even though
I've lost a couple of them and and same
with my you know with my mom you know
her and I are still very very very close
but but I have a you know it's it's kind
of hard to get in with my camp yeah you
know all my guys that open for me have
been friends for 30 years and ever since
I got into comedy so right you feel like
you're like it's like like do you feel
because I feel like I didn't think this
when I started like dating and being in
relationships but I feel just recently
even I've noticed I guess I'm just hard
to connect with I guess it seems like
like what I'm starting to what they said
that's what they said yeah it could be
lying but do you ever feel like that
like do you ever cuz I guess I start to
worry that I'm not gonna be able to have
like a comfortable relationship in my
life and I don't I wonder if it relates
back to my work or if it's maybe just
who I am you know I think it's just who
you are yeah yeah it's now you know I
don't know I always feel like I'm
emotionally available at some point yeah
I feel like I'm not getting what I want
I don't know yeah and then I'm out of
there yeah you know I haven't been in
that many long relationships but but
none of them seem to have worked out
that great except for you know the one
the mother of my son who's still a very
very dear friend of mine today and and
we were married for 12 years and she had
my kid oh wow he got a divorce she got a
dryer oh that's it I we had a damn
writer and she got the dryer that's
beautiful yeah Wow
and you wish you to have more children
or that's what do you have you have a
boy or girl I have a son that's 28 years
old it's a great kid I don't really have
any regrets anywhere my life
you know I am where I am and I'm happy
with it
you know I'm 61 and still have a vibrant
career and you know and that's pretty
rare yeah
deal you know and you know people are
always asking me you know when I'm gonna
retire which I almost resent the
question but I hear it and I'm like you
know the fans you know they'll decide
yeah you know if they if they're still
interested in what I have to say I'll
still still talk you know
I can't imagine you know not having a
life that I don't do stand-up yeah the
time you think you'll die on a tour bus
you think probably either that or a
really nice hotel or my plane you know
something yeah it'll it'll have a it'll
be loud and I just have a feeling
whenever it happens it'll be loud yeah
do you um did you have any time where
you like took time off of the road and
like like where it started to get to you
or something like that I'm starting to
notice some of those things for myself
sometimes where I start to get a little
bit rattled ah you know I was it a
learning curve my well you know in a way
it was I I did 15 years in clubs and
before blue-collar and yeah the day that
Lily was released on DVD
I could sell out any venue in the
country in seconds and did you say you
can you still feel that feeling in your
in your sometimes yes which yeah holy
[ __ ] yeah cuz we put up cuz I remember
hearing stories about you like there's
all types of wild round white stories
you'd hear just you know that he was out
there you know I mean he was out there
on the right he was just always out
there just traveling doing shows yeah
crazy crazy numbers I thought everybody
I mean I most the guys I knew a road
comics yeah it's different than in LA
comic around New York comics
usually the road comics live in the
Midwest which is you know if you're if
you want to be a comedian that's where
you need to go you know you need to go
where you're doing 9 shows a week
every week yeah staying on stage not as
your just you know [ __ ] grassland for
scraps you know yeah so and I saw that
kind of early on I came out and and
headlined a room I shouldn't have been
headline and got horrible reviews and
and I went I need to go back to the
Midwest and sharpen the blade for
another decade Wow and then see what
happens and that's what I did
of course the bad review was just
something that made me scare the area
anyway yeah it was pretty personal you
know don't think of personal I'm like
well it's kind of picture me making a
face I swear to god I've never made but
there it is and and the guy wrote it was
it was watching White's 41 minutes show
is like watching a polar bear lumber
around on stage something comical or
interesting happening only occasionally
huh so you can tell how much impact that
had on me because I still can quote it
yeah and then it but then it was a you
know the it was you know six by twelve
inch thing with a big picture and yeah
and then a big black friend uh said even
when White's not blue he's not funny
he's not funny in big black letters and
I was like oh no not hurt my feelings
man yeah that's a stinger and and I
thought it was the end of my career yeah
because I thought that they'd fire me
and send me home and I'm like well I did
two shows already surely they gotta pay
me for that you figure out how am I
gonna use this money for rent for the
rest of my life yeah right it's gonna be
tough and to stretch this out or even
get home and damn that must have been
devastating it was I went across the
street I was playing this it was the
stop yeah last stop in Newport Beach mhm
and and the the two weeks before I was
there was Seinfeld and Slayton and I've
been to a stand-up for three years so I
should have been beaten with a rubber
hose
which I was yeah I got beat with a
rubber hose that was the best thing that
ever happened to me it was somebody to
go sha whop you know get to get a more
realistic view of where you're at right
now in this business and and and even
though the years later the guy who wrote
it
apologized to me and because it was so
brutal but frankly he wasn't really nice
to anybody he wrote for the Orange
County edition of the LA Times
sounds like a mistress and yeah so he
like Fred Greenlee and a couple of other
people but never heard of that guy not
that he's a bad guy but though ya know
he's but it was a bit of a dick yeah but
that's what it would have taken to get
me to notice you know feet of washed it
over you know if you know you're there
to review comedy right you see a show
that's not up to par that's the one you
chew on and pretty chewed on it you find
like I like so many of these like people
that write articles and they're all from
like New York or LA and they don't even
have like a concept I feel like
sometimes and not in a bad way they just
don't have a perspective of what a lot
of other people think is funny or were a
lot of other people's point of view
comes from so a lot of times like when I
read a lot of articles is just always
painting a lot of like my favorites is
like you know these guys are an immuno
these guys are animals that they're too
loud or it's like what are you talking
about these some of these are just it's
entertainment right yeah I read some
really unflattering things about
Chappelle's Show and I just seen it yeah
and it was written by some comic wannabe
in Australia and I'm like okay well I'm
gonna go watch your show not sure I can
find it and I'll tell you how you stack
up against your pal because I just
watched his I just seen his show in
Santa Barbara off the conflict we were
walking by this theater and he was
playing there that night and I bought
tickets Mao went in there watched it it
was fantastic got a blast yeah and I'm a
pretty good critic stand-up comedy I
mean I do have a
at least a triple doctorate in this
artform the point my opinion is the only
one that matters to me not some young
dude that wants to go bashing on
Chappell yeah for whatever reasons yeah
yeah so in that point you know that
thing is true
I've had people write very very
flattering things about me too so I'm
sure the truth is somewhere in the
middle of that yeah
do you um do you do you ever fear or
have you ever feared that like you would
have written like your best material
like that you come to a point like that
in your career at certain points you're
like this I'll never write something
better than that uh you know I wrote
baby duck [ __ ] lip tacos this year I
know that I've ever written anything
funnier than four seasons you know I've
heard that man I've told my friends
about that bit actually anal bleaching
that was a you know it I think it's hard
to come up with for me because I'm I do
everything in story form and that you
know I find it harder and harder to come
up with just a great new closer yeah but
but just material as long as I go out
and do sets and do the work you know and
then then I wrap you know I can still
write but I've never been prolific at
all you know yeah
CK comes out with a special every 12
months I come out with whenever about
every 40 months
yeah and it's last someone that good the
sex charges or whatever that was that
you know here's okay yeah I mean I think
yeah so he's gonna be well you know I've
talked about that one time and he says
that if I that he you know I like to let
him sit on the vine because I've seen
these bits get really ripe and so it's
when stuffs falling off the trees that's
you use it they put it out in special
yeah but do you ever think that you were
like did you ever worry that your
whatever the thing inside of you or
something that made you be able to be
you your creativity was your worry that
that was going to you know just like dry
up
yeah and you know what what dries up is
the effort hmm you know I can still do
it you know in conversation I'm still
very funny you know to most people and
and but do I have the fear of course I
have the figure you know I've got a new
Netflix special out right now yeah well
I don't have another show you know so I
was risque there that I was I was going
to go out and do a set and the crowd was
gonna stare at me go really not but it
turns out you know they want to see
alive and most of them haven't seen it
and so seems like since that come out
came out I'm walking out on stage two
full standing ovations and and just
murdering with that dude just doing that
special for them and then they cut some
stuff out of it and then doing some
older stuff at the end which I've never
done
right and and they're digging that yeah
you know I you know it's there's
definitely time to really work on
replacing it but as long as they're
doing what I'm doing you know it's it's
I think that's my fifth or something
yeah it's real besides the blue-collar
stuff and it's a lot and you know I feel
like and I'm proud of every one of them
I mean I think they were all in some way
you know pretty good work yeah when you
uh was there so going back to kind of
that moment when things kind of changed
and suddenly you could sell tickets it
was more like you know your material
hadn't really changed you were just mark
you were marketable I guess at that
point or whatever the time is our people
were looking at you now and seeing you
yeah what happened was that first blue
collar album sold four million copies
and
and the and that's one of the biggest
selling games of all time comedy albums
was blue collar one and and two and so
you know and and something you always do
with comedy albums if you really like
them you really pass them around a lot
right I used to go everywhere with a
copy of let's get small in my cassette
okay so I could just play it for people
and didn't take credit for how good it
was that's awesome and so I mean I was
more famous then that I am now yeah just
because of all you know they're probably
80 million people or more even more than
that had seen it on Comedy Central even
you know he said sure Laura bought the
DVD
yeah or whatever so so the impact it
made on my life financially was
unbelievable because you know I went
from you know making but I think when I
was on blue collar maybe by five grand a
week usually maybe a little more yeah
I'd be less and then I went to make it
at least a quarter of a million a week
that's crazy
every week and sometimes as much as six
and so but that part happened just like
that how big is that bag the money
because it's a big bag in a big bag of
money and and I didn't know what to do
you know I the buying anyway do you buy
a boat no no but but but I bought you
know I'm finding I was not you know I
were you drinking like a crazy person
Lincoln every I'd be drinking Mercury
with that kind of money right well
that's the thing I'll be drinking
somebody else's blood they get a hundred
and forty dollar piss every morning I
don't know it was that crazy was it
crazy sometimes like to be sitting in a
nice hotel room and be like this is the
dream like I'm now living in the because
before that it's a dream oh yeah it's a
dream I didn't even have I mean even
though Foxworthy blown up standing right
next to me I had never had any
expectation of being here that kind of
stuff believe me not one bit I had no
confidence that I was ever good
be more than a club headliner and I like
being a club headline yeah you know so I
didn't care but I just you know I saw
people that I thought were better than
me not getting it I see you know Jenny
for one I thought rich Jenny was one of
the best comedians that ever lived and
and he would make it to clubs for I mean
from out of the clubs into the theaters
for a little while but he would never be
able to sustain it and even though the
you know his specials were off the hook
and then and then he ends up you know
often himself in a shower and so I I've
always you know kind of kind of like I
kind of just looked at it a different
way
yeah like what about that guy right if
that guy doesn't get it why would I get
it you know and I did this day I think
Jimmy's a better comic than me and but
it didn't you know it turned out the way
it turned out so but if something has to
happen now yeah you know I never knew
why I made such a strong connection with
these people do you now know why do you
have any idea now when you I you know
because it's interesting like I said
you're my mother's favorite comedian and
you're also my stepbrothers favorite
comedian and they they're 45 years
difference in age you know yeah I
understand what I'm good at and you know
that as far as being just a pace rhythm
timing storyteller
I know that I'm I'm really good at that
yeah I know I can work on microphone I
know that I could work very very subtly
I don't move very much on the stage and
I which makes you look at my eyes which
helps me lie to you right and so like a
polar bear man I know how or a goose
they got that part right at least in
that article the polar bear or it's kind
of right yeah they nailed it they're
kind of captivating they moose you know
but yeah it's interesting I'm trying to
think of what it is I've seen you a
bunch of times at the Comedy Store
yeah I mean I grew you know I've seen
your stuff over the years I'm trying to
think of it
you know being able to be closer to you
now and see what the Comedy Store what
it is definitely the pace kind of
there's like a comfortable hypnosis kind
of that goes on a little bit I also I
feel like as a viewer I want to get to
know I don't care about I mean I love
the jokes and materials great but I want
to get to see Ron white you know like I
want to get to see him just be him and
there's something that's that's
different than some other artists you
you go to hear their jokes you know it's
like oh they'll have a great bit or
something but with you I feel like man
it's um well it is weird it's almost
like yeah polar bear you want to see
them they're kind of it you know not an
endangered species but they're uh you
know you don't get to see them
everywhere right yeah I really don't
know it's just like I said you know I've
seen people better at it than me yeah
that that didn't get what I've been
given as a you know as an entertainer
and so and I try to be humble and accept
it and you know and I've never been
arrogant about my skills as a comedian
yeah although I know I'm really good at
something right but right it did happen
you know I was turns up but but you know
you also got to have a catalyst to make
it happen I had the perfect storm of a
catalyst which means well you may
already know what it means but yes I got
Andrea Gail moon you know II did ten
minutes upfront and then an eight minute
long story so that's 18 I got famous
famous famous of eighteen minutes of
material Wow
so I've still got this stuff I've been
writing for 16 years nobody's ever heard
it took tour with right so so such a
blessing I was really really ready for
that opportunity yeah and then I got fit
I watched it coming I'm like well it
just works I'm gonna get famous off a no
material and most people burn their
first an hour you know like like like
Jenny did or like Rich shiner did or
like oh you know they'll burn that hour
and then how's that second how we're
gonna you know stand up well I didn't
burn it you know I'm right and you just
threw a stick in the fire and next thing
you know you still had a bandha you know
had a show to tour with that nobody had
ever seen Milan it was bald
you know polished over 16 years and it
was you know something I was doing in
the club's you know 290 days a year and
as many as 3 sets a night so you know I
was I was a beast of a club common yeah
oh I could I can't even fathom so and
that's why I still you know that's why I
still do sets every night you know if
you Yassine you up at the company store
all the time I'm always shocked them
like wow right because it's easy just to
sit over here and smoke weed and drink
yeah which I will also but yeah do you
have do you have like a um was it hard
to feel like deserving of your success
and fortunate not your success because
that's kind of based on what you do is
it hard to feel like deserving of like
the accolades and stuff like you know
what I'm saying kind of isn't it I don't
I don't take them that serious right you
know and I wouldn't be if people want to
tell me how great I am
yeah you know I understand what they're
looking at you know and and we're where
they're getting that idea right but I
don't give it any credibility and and if
somebody really hates my work I have a
tendency to agree with them for a second
you know I'm like yeah right
well that's true right that's so true I
do that take it or leave it myself but
you know what I think that's really is
kind of the best approach to come at it
from anyway you know why is it that we
can hear the one person that doesn't
like her we can know if that one person
in the audience of 5,500 people they
didn't laugh and that's the only person
I know that's the only person I could
see what is that why is that you think
yeah you know I don't know maybe it's
just part of our genetic makeup yeah you
know makes us so insecure that we have
to get up in front of people every night
and get some attention yeah
I don't know mine is fairly common
though you know I don't find any of the
really big comics that I know to be
particularly air again about what they
do even though what they do is
impossible to do right you know to build
the career stacking words yeah you know
and I'm doing it with a tenth grade high
school education out of fridge you're
right that's awesome yeah that does that
part you know I beat myself up a lot for
not having a formal education of any
kind but but my brain won't do that
right my brain does this and all it does
you know it doesn't I can't do
conventional school work just I was just
completely lost with it and just a
really short attention span and
attention deficit disorder yeah I was
just lexical fog that's not gonna it was
freelance now everybody's doctored into
it right yeah back then you just got on
the short bus into the [ __ ] class
and which I did and and eventually you
know I started doing drugs fairly early
and and then um and I him my sister was
a lot of trouble so nobody really
noticed what I was a ho Wow yeah and and
but it turned out I was up to quite a
bit and yeah so like I got kicked out of
high school and were you bad were you
bad or were you rebellious what were you
mean I just try to have some fun you
know I don't know I was like no no not
at all I don't mean bone in my body
were you a clown of you a wordsmith like
what was your thing I was a do as a
clown and
you know that was why people like me I
was funny yeah but you know I was in
Houston in the you know around 70s
you know 71 there was a big psychedelic
scene there oh wow and Houston and
Houston yeah I called Allen's landing it
my parents used to take us down there to
look at the hippies bad so there are
people on acid with flowers in her hair
I mean trip yeah you know or early you
know just like Haight Ashbury yeah
Houston in a place called Allen's
landing and and we take it down there
like they were zoo it's awesome and it
was bizarre to see I bet you they see
everything bus but gypping it was girls
would put a ass LSD in their vagina you
know and it would be like this you know
kind of this phase he just reminded me
of that whenever you were saying that
yeah LSD wasn't super big bus but
mushrooms were and then sometimes we
would get acid but I can't believe that
they had I would never think of houston
as having that know well number one all
Houston's just like all was at one time
it was this big around as a thimble it's
surrounded by cattle ranches and as it
grew it just cut into those cattle
ranches when all those cattle ranches
were full of mushrooms that's right
really strong mushrooms and you go to
the end of any Street Houston and that's
where the cattle ranch is now and that's
what the mushrooms all go out and you
can pack a trash bag full of oh yeah
minutes I had no idea they were worth
money somewhere in the world you know
you can get more and used to because
we're like I'm good yeah good did I love
doing mushrooms do you guys do them too
knows we are growing up all the time
yeah I still do yeah now it's become is
it interesting to see how drugs have
become especially living in California
they're more of a medicine and stuff out
here a little bit do you notice that
yeah I do what I do with those shrooms
is a micro dose every day and I do these
little calves a capsule of these shrooms
friend of mine growing mm-hmm and it's
not enough to get you high it's just
enough to make you laugh at [ __ ] any
funny well it's to kind of turn you up a
little a little bit just a little bit
yeah do you did you ever get like way
deep out and I'm like when you were
young like we used to get law
and I remember like I felt like I just
you know melted one time I did you guys
ever get twisted I brought a bag to a
party one time gave him everybody and
then started a game of hide-and-go-seek
a lot of people had never done them in
[ __ ] I don't know what happened half
those people you know I'm sure they're
fine I mean who knows it right now yeah
you know well I also have a DOS you know
for for concerts yeah yeah and that's
you know I gotta tell you even though
it's controversial statement I believe
it 61 years old eat the mushrooms to go
to the concert you know go have fun and
because sitting around in the house
thinking that you're 61 years old that's
no fun yeah that's true we just went to
Santa Fe and we went to this place
called me out wolf never heard of that
huh that's crazy
crazy stuff look it up folks meow wolf
Santa Fe New Mexico it's the most
amazing thing I've ever seen and in it
somewhere it's it's a it's amazed it's a
trip maze hmm it was built by the guy
who did Game of Thrones the writer and
yeah I think the creator Wow and and you
can fact check me on that but I know he
had something to do with somebody with
Game of Thrones and it's like specially
just designed what is it it's a it was a
bowling alley at one time that they dug
out huge and you go into a door and
there's a house and you go into the
house and you look for clues on how to
get to other portals so you might open a
refrigerator yeah and then go through
this stairway that it takes you into
another world and it's a journey right
and depending on what you see changes
your journey plan which way you go in
this thing and you guys did it oh yeah
we did it tripping balls
but on those nights it was there's a for
about a 400 person venue live music
venue in it somewhere
so that night a friend of ours named
shakey graves from Austin was there
great [ __ ] show me shakey graves is
so goddamn good is he as good as it gets
it's a man yeah yeah it's a he used to
play on the streets of Austin with a
with a tip jar and so saying is he he's
got a suitcase that he built the kick
drum in and and then he's got a low-rise
symbol and so he plays guitar with and
then he plays that cymbal with one foot
and plays that kick drum with his other
heel yeah and so it's a one-man band
kind of thing and he's just insanely
talented and now he sells out Red Rock
I'm Denver you know he's a big touring
act and he has it for him but he comes
out by himself at first and that's where
his fans want to see they just want to
see him and that kick drum and that you
know but he has a band that he does a
lot of the show with and at the end of
it he comes out just by himself and just
been it is [ __ ] fun dang so I see so
a lot of tonight is uh dude the
mushrooms and go to the concert yeah
don't say oh yeah go have some [ __ ]
fun yeah I guess people just get too
caught up in there is it I guess it's
their habits or they just yeah wonder if
people start to live into this idea of
what they feel like it has to be as you
as we get older you know
I don't know I'm just saying yes the
mushrooms go to the concert you know you
said live in Mexico and I lived on the
American side of the border said McAllen
Texas and Reynosa Mexico is the border
town I had a pottery factory there and
this is a boat before I moved to Mexico
I lived in a trailer and in this kind of
a fenced-in community but you could have
campers there so some people were living
in those campers or khakis and stuff
okay
and and they I think they think that's a
good idea because they used to go
camping and it was fun what was fun
about camping is you got drunk and you
know whatever ran it was like yeah so
they're getting drunk every night they
just sitting these campers they've
decided to go camping for the rest of
their lives and the only thing that
makes it tolerable is just a just huge
amounts of liquor right that's that's
what does it and so they and they've
there's usually a man a woman they got
nothing else to say to each other so
we're sneaking out you know because if
one of them catches you
they got 65 years of stuff you haven't
heard and they're dying to tell some
Dadon heard it you know they're looking
for a new audience yeah and which I get
and so you know I think they're right if
you're gonna live in RV better be
willing to drink it's gonna suck yeah
and I live in an RV yeah it's a nice one
but I still live in one you know do you
feel more at home there a lot of times
in the bus yeah I like it
because it's usually got my friends on
it it's always stocked I don't have to
carry stuff to it I've owned it for 12
years or something like that and you
know it's big 45 foot Prevost and was it
scary when it started to feel like home
some was that a little spooky or no you
know I've always seems like been able to
roll with the punches you know wherever
my life was that
didn't seem to matter that much to me
this weather I lived in a really nice
place we didn't live in a really nice
place now it would be hard to go back to
yeah any other life than the one I have
right now and I don't have to so right
but now it's just a big you know at one
time here my best friend who passed away
yeah remember me he told me about him he
wrote minutes I was my be happy guy Alex
Roy mundo is my opening act great the
bus driver built the bus and so you know
when I'd see my bus coming I know I know
all those people are on there and I'd
have grey liquor and grey weed and great
company and and and it was a Rovin
circus I mean we were doing up to 145
cities you know four and five a week and
you know just but it you know it was
just that's just what was going on in my
life now I still do a 110 which is more
than probably most people do yeah but I
just don't think I could I don't think I
could slow down without stopping you
know I think that you still have to like
I said stay on stage all the time to be
good at it and that's true actually two
weeks off and you feel if something
feels wrong yeah it feels different
you're skiing I can tell it when I was
doing 9 cents a week when I go to
another club and have a day off those
you know getting used to the sound
system where you don't get to do that
anymore because I'm in another town
tomorrow night anyway yeah but now
they're big theatres and most of them
have somebody who knows what's going on
but I remember being better on Wednesday
that I was on Tuesday and and sharper by
the weekend and so so now at 61 you know
still the same you know I feel like that
uh that it's easy to lose that you know
you lose you lose it pretty fast
yeah and I've really never seen anybody
stop completely and ever regain any
momentum particularly has that changed
over the years where like if you've
taken a couple days off when you were
younger or at a younger age and now at
61 that the
the bounce back time is that always just
been seemed like the kind of the same a
little bit well I mean I just kind of
know how to do it now if I had a week
off I mean I'm off this weekend so
whatever said I did last I watch it just
to get it all floating back at the top
again you know that's so you could
snatch it yeah how quick so but I'll
just sit down and watch the last set
that I did and and that usually that'll
keep the first set for being too you
know too shitty yeah but don't go to
Thursday night shows that's what I'm
trying to tell oh really yeah the
mushrooms go to the concert don't go to
my Thursday go to the Saturday do you
miss or is there anything that you miss
about being poor you know like sometimes
I start to think about that like I'll
started to just make a little bit of
money like I start to wonder like other
things that I'm gonna miss about are
things that I do miss sometimes about
you know having less money I used to do
some really fun stuff that I don't do
anymore like tube and rivers and yeah
that you know really good poor people
fun it was real fun yeah and so and I
blame it on how busy I am but you know
but I you know I I was I was already you
know I already had a nice warm place to
sleep and I ate good food the food the
same food I like now and you know I
other than the you know obviously the
house are nice the car is nice and stuff
like that it's it's not like I was I had
never felt deprived Ryan however Ryan so
you know it's it's certainly different
and but you know it's not like I was
coming from I didn't feel like my life
is lacking before I made it right yeah
it was one night you and I were hosting
the you and I were judging the roast
battle upstairs you know that Comedy
Central show they have roast battle so I
got you know and you didn't know me from
Adam or anything and I was one of the
judges sitting next to you well they
give out that weed up there sometimes
that speed we company or something you
know
right so I don't know one of us lit lit
up a joint and then pass it to the other
one and I took after the second hit man
I couldn't I didn't know if you were on
white dude or you know or I didn't know
how was Ron white [ __ ] I don't know who
was Ronnie white you know and you yeah
yeah and you kept hitting it and I kept
getting so scared I was like holy [ __ ]
like there's no way that Ron is gonna be
able to you know make it through this I
had to have is the only night ever I had
to have a girl drive me home in my car
from the Comedy Store and take me into
my apartment and put me to sleep you
know and not in a fun way you know like
and that was uh and you must hit it nine
more times an idea that was over two
years ago yeah
cuz you've been sober for two years to
be under your fans know your you been
sober
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] it's
fun and then it's not fun like right now
it's not fun you know I definitely wish
I could probably get you know smoke
again with Ron White and you know catch
an uber it's not worth it I wouldn't do
it but I got no choice why do you feel
like these days you have to you have to
drink or party I guess it's part of the
lifestyle huh well I kind of just
thought my hope a new plan is eat the
[ __ ] mushrooms to go to the concert
so yeah you know I I used to do I used
to drink a lot more than I do now and I
used to smoke a lot more than I do now
and I say that with a drink and a joint
in one in each answer yeah so it's
really kind of hard to believe right
folks but back when I was a scotch
drinker I drank tequila now and I own
this company it's called number one
tequila yeah yeah people have said it's
good a lot of my friends have tasted
crazy what's in it the GAVI and water
damn I love that's it that's it huh
there are no other additives there's two
people just hug him by the VAT while
they're making it a bet huh oh yeah yeah
then that's the thing I drink scotch for
ever and late at night I drink a lot of
scotch I started to get morose which
makes
nobody horny yeah just that's that Edgar
Allan Poe syndrome huh is that what it
is I think yeah he's always said morose
he always said yeah
things were dark you know he was always
writing about people dying and
everything right yeah my sides actually
related to him is he really yeah Dan
some kind of great-great-great-great
uncle Edgar Allan Poe Edgar Allan Poe
damn
yeah the Raven baby anybody else in the
family that's uh no I had your allen
made some huh yeah so you mean me I mean
Edgar Allan came oh he's pretty
fascinating human being - he's very
engaged in in life yeah and liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and that's cool
do you wish you two had more children or
do you consider it still having some no
I no absolutely no no no I mean there
every once in a while I'll date somebody
with a couple of kids and wonder if I
could possibly take myself to a place
where you know I'm actually you know
responsible for somebody with damnit
which I certainly didn't when I had my
son ya know so I doubt I'll do it for
somebody else right
my son literally I got joint custody
with my son
Oh Congrats ooh and a half years old oh
really yeah so and I didn't even deserve
half but I got half so literally they're
like all right you want half there you
go
here's a baby he's all yours knock
yourself silly
and I'm like wow so I'm touring around
in my van I got a vamp driving two gigs
in and what kind of van was it out to a
stroke van and now it was a custom van
Brenner TV oh that's nice and I mean
nothing like what I get now bright it
was still you could sleep in it if you
wanted to and had a place to you know
anyway and you had the baby in there so
I had a baby toured with me me and
there's a little baby I mean I don't
know why that's not a movie yeah and
literally I'm in comedy clubs walking up
to waitresses right before I go to stage
what they could do is hold him
45 minutes I'll be right back down don't
even beer he likes it just don't give it
to him and and and he was so hip to the
comedy scene and sometimes I would take
him onstage you know anything to get you
laughing and and we he was maybe five
years old was he good baby I was perfect
and would you feed him you to speed him
just road food just chilling oh yeah
because I need you to play those plastic
balls while I've nursed this hangover
yeah I mean I was it was horrible i
reaiiy really give myself a lot of grief
buddy had a great stepdad and it still
does a guy named Terry well I shouldn't
say his name but a guy Terry
Terry's are usually [ __ ] weird I think
right the ones I've come across no
offense if somebody's Terry but this one
was good yeah this was amazing
and you know we're you know he and I are
opposite is the spectrum and and I don't
think for a really long time he
particularly liked me at all and and he
had a couple of daughters that were one
a little younger and I think a little
older than us so he was already raising
children he was into fatherhood that
yeah right yeah he was an accountant and
uh yeah he was doing it yeah he's a damn
adult right he's an adult and I'm a
[ __ ] club comic you know who the baby
can't even imagine that well I can't
imagine what made him
ever agree to it you know because they
could have just talked bad about me
enough in court to get him to not do it
did you fight for joint custody it seems
like I must have yeah cuz how do you get
I don't know but you know I wouldn't
give me a baby
you can't dial it back you know let's do
20% yeah I think that's a Josh blue bit
but but it but it all adds up to who he
is now and I mean we lived in Mexico
when he was 5 years old and he took him
from the road to Mexico this is Mexico
to make pottery and and we lived in
Reynosa Mexico which now you wouldn't go
in there where the armed really it's
wild huh but when I was there was great
I mean it was it was magnificent best
food best people the he and I ate at
this killer taco stand across stream is
little Church which was across the
street my house and a cute little
community and and we loved it there and
does he have fond member does your son
have fond memories of it or does he like
hold that kind of stuff against you I
you know I think that he has fond
memories of it and and I you know it's a
really really really good question but
it doesn't feel like I mean because we
talk every day and we into every
conversation with I love you yeah
everyone and that's cool so I think if
there ever was any animosity and also he
also got to see my life completely broke
don't have a dime I don't have enough
money to get me in the water park yeah
I'm gonna tell him I'm sick because I
got $12 16 cents and yeah you can't
stand there as an adult if I can look
into a water park dude that's the right
not a good look you can't come up with
the cash so well no even this is an
adult standing there watching children
play is you know even back then it was
wild but yeah I can't imagine that like
telling your son that and you guys
having to find creative ways to spend
time to get
there you know my dad used to take us to
funerals in town dude the [ __ ] you
know for something for us to do you know
like I think if he resumed him for it
because I work you know I think in some
way like you're saying maybe as an adult
now 38 now I see somehow it probably
helped me and at least he did something
you know he made some effort you know
because that's the thing he made some
effort he could have just done nothing
you know he could have just oh here I
was telling a story and I got off the
track where he's he's four or something
like that and I said okay it's time to
go to the club and he goes he goes
alright damn but I don't want to go on
stage tonight I just want to hang out in
the green room and I said oh this club
doesn't have a green room and he goes oh
it's a funny bone the funny bones God
dig for dimes we can't spare two hundred
square feet to make you guys that's
Baton Rouge funny bone man that's where
I started out at in that place there was
I mean everybody was related in the
crowd you know this was this is kind of
a down in Baton Rouge and it was fun
everybody was just more football fans
than they were comedy fans in a way you
know he's just hard to get him to be
quiet to listen but right but also at
the same time they had 325 people in
there every show oh yeah
yeah I played that and I played the
greenroom one called the greenroom there
there was a ancient from Baton Rouge in
veneration yeah I always loved that
sound that sound parties you you you can
start party in that town and nobody will
stop nobody everybody will a get on we
were just down in New Orleans playing
the Saenger and just had a great goddamn
time how's that theater they just redid
it last year that's perfect yeah as good
as it gets and and as you know it's it's
still well you know I do my Friday after
the show dough so much yeah you know
Bourbon Street still burning the hint of
vomit and piss
and a bunch of fun yeah is there a place
where you don't tour anymore that's just
like and no particular reason but expert
Mississippi yes because the venue sucks
and the and the you know the crowds are
just you know they're every I'm sure
that 99.9% of them I'm sure the 75%
absurd that 66% of people the too many
[ __ ] knuckleheads huh and it was just
it was bad one year that I came back I'm
like [ __ ] my back here for and but I
love the South yeah and I and I don't
see that to be the case everywhere but
it would just is one of these things
where this guy's just gonna take over
the world there's three guys that are
security guards right down there and I'm
like throw him out you're like what's
your [ __ ] job you all talk to me like
that like now I'm with the security
security guard and then it got worse a
bit worse where all the security guards
were like man you can't come into this
tab and then there's big Oh redneck I
told you alright yeah you guys win so
there you go yeah there's some places it
is kind of wild like there's some places
where the crowds like I am innocent
Minnesota but sometimes I've like they
don't laugh as hard sometimes as other
places sometimes in the south when it
gets to like so you get somebody that's
to rural they just don't know how to
behave indoors you know those are some
things that I'll notice has I think
comedy you know in general comedy
audiences are more educated than ever
and so I think I find more good yeah
then then then bad and that's you know
because they're watching so many things
on TV that most people really kind of
get it did you sit there and listen and
respond to what they say yeah and even
though you know not all the time but
still even with even with the big crowds
I'm playing now I find especially within
the last couple of years
you know they've been pretty
well-behaved and and I'll Hal I throw
somebody out of my show in a New York
second if I get somebody to do it yeah
I'm not gonna change shirts and go down
there with a Taser dude in a Shreveport
they used to have a club there
Shreveport funnybone and they had a man
there and after the show he would tease
you he was like an off-duty cop if you
wanted him to you know you could do it
with him but and I remember getting
[ __ ] tased one night me and another
guy they talked me into it
and that feel not good man really
surprising that you did it
no just the exact moment of it it even
it's more surprising than you think it
would be right yes involuntary knee-jerk
oh yeah spit tile coming out of there
and you what I felt really young for a
second too though I remember that I
remember feeling just there was this you
still look extraordinarily well thanks
thought you were 28 oh no I well well
you had that long hair man you and I had
an ideal lesbian haircut so if you took
your old one you know right I mean ideal
man yeah there's some where there's a
new picture of me floating around the
mother Senate Zoo minutes and I'm in a
campground somewhere and I've got this
long curly hair down to here with a Bob
Marley t-shirt cigarette hanging out of
my mouth and you could and I know
exactly where we are because you can see
a river in the background so I know
we're at the lazy L&L campground on the
Guadalupe River where we used to go to
both oh wow
I guess the real that's what maybe adds
a real picture Wow and I'll show it to
you before you go it's on the phone but
it but you know they I think they kind
of takes me back to even when I said so
I think I even mentioned tube in a river
and I think that's why I think I because
I just saw that picture oh I see I
remember we used to go 20 or 30 of us
you know down there camp at how much
[ __ ] fun it was yeah and
and I mean just an unbelievable amount
of fun nothing funner look forward to it
every and wait to go I remember sitting
in the two-man if people would maybe
stop off on a shore with a chick and
hook up or something or just keep
drinking somebody do mushrooms somebody
would drown sometimes he was like [ __ ]
it you know not my time to go you know
you just keep cruising one night this
guy's with a girl on the side of the
bank just shooting a gun into the water
and we're floating up towards when I'm
yelling I'm like hey and he's like he
stops shooting goes what and then start
shooting again in between my answer I
said well you stop shooting that gun and
he's like why I'm like cuz we're [ __ ]
about to float by you know like that had
never crossed his head you know somebody
might not be hip to some small fire erm
yeah I just don't you know I don't know
how you know how much I could dodge
right now but yeah I used to I used to I
really really loved that did Whizzer you
know sometimes people invite me to do
stuff and I feel like it's not as much
fun as it is going to do comedy for me
is gonna be did you ever feel that way
yeah you know people really they invite
me to play a lot of golf and but I'm
such a golf snob that I'm hesitant to
say yeah sure I'll go spend four hours
with you right on I don't know how good
it is Golf Course right and so in that
way yeah probably but but is anything
more fun for you than doing stand-up
though yeah you know I don't guess you
know it's it's just so it's just so much
a part of my makeup and you know who I
am and that I just you know it's it's
what keeps me alive and makes me feel
young and you know vital and so you you
know that I don't think anything's that
much fun yeah me alright if it was you
know he do it right I would be doing
that
yeah yeah you seem super vital man I
appreciate your time sitting in chat
with us and um yeah we'll put you know
obviously all your date's out and stuff
and yeah man I hope you keep going for a
million more years I think that's what
we got written down on the calories yeah
now about a million more years yeah you
know I think that that as long as I keep
working and the fan Steve keeps coming
out and they're gonna see no reason to
you know to slow down it's not that hard
who was one of your favorite people that
you ever got to make laughs Hicks
laughter one bit that I did it was and
it was I haven't forgot how it was set
up but it was going to the desk of the
hotel god you don't even wake up call
for seven o'clock and the lady goes mr.
white is 5/7 I said no the next one I
think you got another one coming around
so Hicks with Hicks was at the show yeah
so and I didn't see him laughs somebody
else said that's cool all right I had to
lift you up huh oh yeah yeah yeah for me
it was Damon Wayans one night in the
back of the room I heard him laugh and
I'd heard him laugh growing up on
television and it just like oh so you
recognize the sound of it like that and
it just was like that's it that's
awesome yeah Ron thanks so much for your
time man and um and I'll see you around
the Comedy Store man thanks for having
me on your show yeah you bet
[Music]
it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]